[Musica]
questa sera vi racconto la storia di
come io elena favilli siamo passati
dall'essere due persone che lavoravano
nella cucina di un appartamento di 60
metri quadri a venice beach a los
angeles a dirigere un'azienda con uffici
a los angeles new york e londra ea
creare uno dei best seller che ha un po
diciamo definito un trend nella nella
storia dell'editoria degli ultimi degli
ultimi anni questa storia comincia in
realtà non in california ma comincia a
milano
io ero una regista di the facevo la
regista di teatro el autrice di teatro e
elena faceva la giornalista ea un certo
punto ci venne in mente questa idea di
fare una rivista su ipad per bambini
l'ipad stava per uscire quindi adesso
sembrerà banale ma all'epoca quando
l'ipad stava per uscire ci dicemmo
crediamo che questa possa essere una
cosa che piacerà ai bambini
adesso chiunque di voi abbia un figlio
sa che vanno staccati dall ipad con le
bombe e che quindi hanno una passione
sfegatata per per questo strumento
l'idea lì era quella di fare una rivista
non di finzione ma una rivista che
parlasse ai bambini in modo innovativo
dell'attualità perché io sono sempre
stata convinta che i bambini non siano i
cittadini del futuro ma che siano i
cittadini del presente e vadano trattati
come tali
lanciamo questa rivista su ipad io non
venivo dal mondo della tecnologia né dal
mondo dell'impresa e lanciamo questa
rivista e dopo averla lanciata scoprimmo
che era la prima rivista su ipad per
bambini al mondo
iniziamo a capire che quello che stavamo
facendo si poteva chiamare una start up
e iniziamo a metterci alla ricerca di
finanziamenti
ricordo che non avendo nessuna
formazione di economia o di impresa una
delle prime volte che andare a
incontrare degli investitori alla banca
intesa di milano arrivai con questa
presentazione che avevo confezionato un
po alla bella e meglio
copiando il formato da internet e chiesi
a uno degli
detti che mi accompagnava perché la
banca intesa di milano è molto grande
per cui è abbastanza labirintica e ti
devono accompagnare alle riunioni e
chiesi ma ma perché qualcuno dovrebbe
mettere dei soldi nella mia azienda e
loro mi dissero l'ha detto che mi
accompagnava mi disse per comprare
dell'equity e io risposi ma è che cos'è
l'equity e quindi questo era per darvi
un'idea di quanto poco sapessi all'epoca
di come si fa una start up
lui mi disse l'equity è un pezzo della
tua azienda e di qualche tipo di ritorni
si aspettano il 2 il doppio il triplo no
mi dissero questi sono investimenti ad
alto rischio per cui si aspettano di
fare sette otto volte i soldi che che
hanno investito nella tua azienda
quindi io chiesi di andare in bagno e
aggiunti 10 alle proiezioni di tutte le
slide che avevo preparato e non riuscì
quell'incontro non sorprendentemente
forse non andò a buon fine però successe
che attraverso un altro concorso che si
chiamava mind bridge riuscì insieme ad
elena d'andare in silicon valley e a
essere presentata alla partner di un
grosso fondo di investimento che si
chiama 500 start up che forse qualcuno
di voi conosce christine sai che era che
adesso è ceo di five hundred startups
decise di investire i primi 50 mila
dollari in in timbuctu la nostra start
up e da lì iniziò questo percorso
incredibile in cui tante delle porte che
avevamo trovato chiuse anche in italia
quando erano mandate in giro a fare
questi pc per raccogliere per
raccogliere dei capitali improvvisamente
si aprirono riuscimmo a raccogliere un
round investimento di circa 600 mila
dollari e mettemmo in piedi questa
piccola realtà che sviluppava up per
bambini quando si pensava che le app
sarebbero state un grande mercato
in realtà dopo un po di tentativi
nonostante avessimo raggiunto quasi 2
milioni di utenti
abbiamo dovuto sospendere la
pubblicazione di timbuctu magazine
perché non riuscivamo ad avere
abbastanza abbonati a quel punto eravamo
in una situazione molto difficile perché
vedevamo che continuavano a che
l'azienda continua va non solo a non
essere profittevole ma da avere delle
grosse perdite per cui decidemmo di
ripensare l'azienda e ci spostammo da
san francisco a los angeles con il
pensiero che ci continuavano a dire
tutti che dovevamo fare una piattaforma
tecnologica ma noi sentivamo che il
valore maggiore che potevamo produrre
all'interno della nostra azienda era
attraverso il contenuto non attraverso
la tecnologia quindi ci spostammo a los
angeles che un come potete immaginare
essendo la città del cinema è un posto
un po più amichevole per i narratori e
iniziamo a lavorare su una cosa piccola
piccola piccola piccola e cioè mettendo
in piedi una newsletter
partendo da 25 persone 25 persone tra i
nostri amici che pensavamo potessero
essere interessate a storie di
emancipazione femminile da proporre ai
loro figli iniziamo a mandare questa
newsletter che aveva un obiettivo molto
semplice raccontava una volta alla
settimana
una storia che questi genitori potessero
raccontare alle proprie figlie a cena o
prima di andare a dormire
questa newsletter si chiamava gorna
historiques four reborn storie della
buonanotte per bambini ribelli
a un certo punto ci rendemmo conto che
le persone alle persone questa
newsletter piaceva così tanto che
iniziavano a girarsi e la tradisce e
quindi vedevamo gli iscritti crescere
ogni settimana a quel punto io avevo
pubblicato già sei libri con un editore
tradizionale e non ero stata
particolarmente contenta del risultato
per cui quando la newsletter arrivo a
2.000 persone
pensiamo forse questa newsletter
potrebbe diventare un libro e iniziamo a
lavorare sulla costruzione di una
campagna di crowdfunding eravamo
soltanto io e lei lavorando dalla cucina
del nostro appartamento perché come è
noto se gli americani fanno le start up
nei garage gli italiani le fanno nelle
cucine e iniziamo a lavorare a questa
campagna e ad aprile del 2016
lanciamo una campagna di crowd funding
per realizzare il libro my story
con l'obiettivo di raccogliere 40.000
dollari per stampare le prime mille
copie del libro alla fine della campagna
che durava 28 giorni avevamo raccolto
675mila dollari da 13 mila persone
provenienti da 75 paesi
la prima diventando il libro più
finanziato nella storia del crowdfunding
e io ricordo e succede raramente che c'è
un momento nella vita di un imprenditore
di un'azienda in cui tu in in una
questione di minuti inizia a capire che
sta per prendere una svolta quello che
stai facendo
e io mi ritengo molto privilegiato ad
averlo ad averlo vissuto mi ricordo la
mattina del primo giorno di lancio
quando a un certo punto iniziamo a
vedere il primo ordine il secondo il
terzo il decimo nei primi 5 10 minuti e
ci fu questo momento in cui ci
abbracciammo perché capimmo che quello
che avevamo creato poteva funzionare
forse al di là delle nostre più rosee
aspettative
in realtà la prima ristampa di storie
della buonanotte per bambini ribelli non
fu di mille ma di 60.000 copie che senza
essere nelle librerie furono
completamente esaurite prima di natale
uscendo a novembre
grazie
[Musica]
e adesso soltanto tre anni dopo il libro
ha venduto 4 milioni e mezzo di copie ed
è stato tradotto in 48 lingue è stata
una questo è stata un'avventura
incredibile nella quale non tanti autori
si trovano nella posizione di dover
scrivere ed essere autori e quindi
girare il mondo per promuovere il
proprio lavoro mentre costruiscono la
casa editrice che pubblica il libro
perché noi decidemmo di non vendere i
diritti di pubblicazione ad altri
editori che appena videro che la
campagna stava decollando iniziarono a
farci un sacco di offerte per acquisire
i diritti di pubblicazione del libro ma
noi pensiamo che quella era l'occasione
che avevamo cercato così a lungo di
costruire l'azienda che avevamo sognato
e che riflettesse gli stessi valori che
volevamo mettere in quel libro dei
valori di diversità dei valori di
rispetto delle differenze e dei valori
che parlano del rispetto del lavoro
delle donne e per cui lanciamo questo
libro e noi finimmo la campagna a maggio
non avevamo mai pubblicato un libro
prima il libro non era ancora stato
scritto
e ci lanciamo in questa impresa
impossibile di promettere ai nostri
sostenitori che il libro sarebbe stato
nelle loro case a novembre quindi
avevamo pochissimi mesi per capire come
si pubblicava un libro per trovare uno
stampatore per trovare il modo di far
arrivare tutte queste copie nelle case
di tutte queste persone e chiunque ci
avrebbe detto che eravamo completamente
pazze che quella cosa che abbiamo fatto
era impossibile in realtà oggi timbuctu
a più di 20 persone che ci lavorano e
uffici in due continenti
io ci ho lavorato con molto orgoglio
fino a gennaio di quest'anno
da gennaio di quest'anno si è interrotta
per me questa si è interrotta per me
questa avventura e o adesso avviato una
nuova una nuova avventura sono stata in
un momento di grande paura per cui
capisco e tenevo molto anche avvenire a
parlarne qui nella città di taranto
perché tutte le volte che ci sono dei
grandi cambia
momenti all'orizzonte è normale avere
paura di quello che ci aspetta dopo aver
scritto un bestseller di questo tipo e
aver costruito questa realtà io mi sono
trovato in un momento di grande
confusione però quello che ho deciso di
fare è stato di affrontare questo
momento di paura con un gesto creativo
per questo ho deciso di andare a vivere
in un posto nuovo in cui non avevo mai
vissuto prima
ho vissuto ho scelto di prendere una
casa a roma per al quinto piano senza
ascensore in cima a 104 gradini a
trastevere
ho detto vado a farmi una primavera a
roma e cerco di riorganizzare le idee e
ho scelto roma perché normalmente roma a
maggio è uno spettacolo c'è il sole c'è
l'esplosione della primavera
questo maggio è stato tremendo perché ci
sei stato
vento pioggia sembrava invernale un
proprio pieno inverno quindi
ritrovandomi in questa in questa
mansardina al qui al quinto piano ho
iniziato a immaginarmi una storia che
fosse ambientata all'interno della
casetta nella quale stavo vivendo e ho
iniziato a scrivere sul mio quaderno
questa storia che è diventata adesso
elfi al quinto piano che è uscito adesso
con feltrinelli e che ha incontrato io
sono ho incontrato in questo caso un
altro editore che non ha avuto paura
perché sono andata da lui da gianluca
foglia il direttore editoriale di
feltrinelli e gli ho detto io ho scritto
questo libro non è ancora finito ma
vorrei che uscisse a natale ed è un
libro illustrato
chiunque abbia una vaga idea di come
funziona l'editoria sa che questa anche
è una missione impossibile però
tendenzialmente quando si sceglie di
mettere da parte la propria paura si
incontrano altre persone che sono
disposte a fare lo stesso e questo fatto
ho incontrato tante persone nel corso
della mia vita che sono state disposte
in tanti momenti a mettere da parte la
loro paura ea buttare il cuore oltre
l'ostacolo ed è questo che invito voi a
fare è tutta la città di taranto
grazie